As an almost adult, man I gotta say, I would
do anything to get nap time back.
But are there some ways acting like a child,
can make life better as an adult.
Hey guys Julia here for DNews
Well I now have to cut the crusts off my own
pb&js but life is going pretty okay as adult.
I do miss some things, like recess and naps,
but lately research is showing that bringing
back certain kid’s games can do grown ups
some good.
Because researchers can never take things
too seriously, two researchers defined adult
playfulness as “a predisposition to define
and engage in activities in a non-serious
or fanciful manner to increase enjoyment.”
Very… playful, guys.
And grown ups do this all the time.
We go out for karaoke, we ski, we improv,
whatever.
So why do we keep up the games?
Well some research suggests it could help
us find a mate.
One study published in the American Journal
of Play found that playfulness was important
in partner selection.
Participants filled out a survey of desired
traits in a partner, and traits like 'sense
of humor,' 'fun loving' and 'playful' topped
both men and women’s lists.
The researchers suggested this means these
traits arose from sexual selection.
And that maybe playfulness in men suggested
to women that they were less aggressive and
playfulness in women suggested to men that
they were healthy, youthful and maybe fertile.
So what kind of activities do adults “play”?
Well skiing was researched in a study published
in the journal Applied Research in Quality
of Life.
The researchers found that skiing had high
rates of engagement and involvement.
Engagement in this case meaning, you get so
into doing a thing, you lose sense of everything
else around you.
You get lost in it.
Involvement in this case
is how much that activity gives you a sense
of meaning and a sense of being a part of
something greater than yourself.
The researchers suggest that like participating
in fun activities like skiing with high engagement
and involvement helps people grow emotionally
and socially.
One of the researchers said that "Adult playfulness
can influence people's happiness...and contribute
to overall well-being,” Which can buffer
us from life’s stresses.
But if you want to find some peace and don’t
have any ski slopes near you, maybe you should
pick up a coloring book.
One of the most popular adult play activities
lately is coloring.
Not your typical, princess style book either.
Oh no, these coloring books are complex and
intricate.
These patterns repeat and weave across the
page.
These kind of books are helping tons of people
de-stress and relax.
Research like one study published in the journal
Palliative & Supportive Care shows that making
art can often help those who deal with stress
and anxiety and improves coping resources.
Yet facing a blank page can be daunting.
Where do you even start?
But coloring books give us a way into our
creativity without seeming overwhelming.
The lines guide us and all we have to choose
is what color the next flower will be.
It’s definitely an engaging task that helps
us leave our stress behind.
Psychologists say that coloring has a calming
effect.
Psychologist Gloria Martinez Ayala told the
Huffington Post that “The relaxation that
it provides lowers the activity of the amygdala,
a basic part of our brain involved in controlling
emotion that is affected by stress.
So play does all sorts of things for us as
adults!
It helps us focus, helps us destress, and
of course it could even help us land the one.
So go outside and play!
After a ten-year wait, the all-new Tacoma
is finally here.
It’s been fully redesigned to play whenever
and wherever you want.The new Toyota Tacoma
encourages you
to break the rules, and PLAY NOW.